well hello guys hey we're back we're
back on the zoom here back on the serum
nobody's favorite the last one hopefully
the last one should be back in studio
next week here's hoping we got to see it
for negative all that stuff what job
what's new oh you know just living the
life here now again tested today
hopefully comes out negative because
I've had no symptoms for some time now
that's good yeah I cannot say the same
for myself not feeling good no well I
feel a saying which is nothing changes
so that's you know but you talk to
doctors and they're like yeah you know
this one doctor I know had it for three
weeks and I know the guy had terribly
bad for two weeks and was just like it
is what it is
it just manifests itself differently and
everybody I think you know for one thing
you're older too you know retired well
that's because my [ __ ] eyes have
these these circles and I don't know if
that's from the operation but it's not
going away that bothers me losing their
bruising yeah there was but it should be
gone by now but then I guess cope it
doesn't [ __ ] help sir yeah how are
you guys cast nega-chin you got yours
back not yet but I feel better so that's
good so far everybody that we have come
into contact with from what I've come
into contact was tested negative
good some twice same thing kids Brennan
who gotta get some fights out Saturday
I'm stuck in my home so that's gonna I
don't that will chop up the boredom a
little bit daddy he's gonna be no the
lung huh gonna be stuck in your in your
house
that's right buddy but I'm gonna break
down the Feist and I want to get your I
wanted to see what you think of my
breakdown that's it
you want to start with the you want to
start with the main event you want to
start with Jessica and drive didn't
Rhonda and Rosa start with that uh my
favorite fight on the card will top five
is on the main event on the prelims
well those Damaris that Jerry that jury
guys he's from rides and he's the light
heavyweight champ over there he's a
monster
oh yeah I did not know I've seen full
can obviously fight a lot I've not seen
that other guy from Reisman he's a beast
yeah that's a fun fight
and and he they're both because I think
also some heroes made me a striker right
yeah it's gonna be a zone getting
knocked down yeah I do you have anything
to say about any of the tree limb or
early pre-med you're good man they're
really good those Muslims good Bogota
for Santos is given there's a button I
mean the whole it's so funny I was
looking at the best Russian wrestlers of
all time i watch these videos and almost
all of them all the legendary wrestlers
are all from so when you say russian
wrestling they're almost all Dagestan
yeah so far like the top guys so there's
conception tradition to that and then
please organizer but yeah so I'm excited
about the odd Ronde rose namajunas fight
because Rose was piecing her up and and
and you know when Jessica picked run
throughout her head obviously she can
avoid that I mean she's so god damn
strong but I don't think there's any
comparison in terms of skill level
striking etc probably eating jiu-jitsu I
think the only danger is all due respect
but the only danger is for her to get
picked up and thrown around head again I
don't see her no is not fair to do to
just and ROG so I'm not a former champ
she's not just gonna pick it up and
thrown
she's up no she's not she has really
good striking well what Rose is a big
favorite though yes she comes forward
though like when she the way she did
with the tank I shame she just comes
straight forward and with that check
hook in that jab I don't know man it's
gonna be tough with to fight Rose that
way it didn't work the first time and
there's a change in plans
I don't know how that works the second
time so Rose should get it done yeah you
skip one thought that Paige Vanzant
she's the biggest dog on the card which
is interesting because I girl who she's
fighting the Brazilian Amanda yeah this
is pages of plus 600 that Amanda Reba's
is - wow it's not really yeah Reba's
losses have been she got clipped you
know and that can can crack a little bit
it's not terrible I mean - 900 Jesus
Christ can you explain what that means
betting wise I mean you gotta put nine
hundred dollars on Amanda to win a
hundred G's it's not yeah that's that's
that's that's at that level it's not a
bad bet to take Paige like you would be
out of this world
page one that's funny right right that's
good and then what about let's see
what's the next fight let me see if he
wins it'd be the biggest win let me to
speak it'd be shocking and incredible
but Jana such a [ __ ] beast is boxing
so ridiculously good he's younger it's
like his time and it's really Lauren
yeah I don't have that much momentum
like everyone's is definitely good but
you know Jo Jo I thought you on the
glass fight against and people prizes
that he's done work man I think you know
Peter young hasn't had like that huge
signature when he is nowhere near the
experience
again it's salad if you're trying to
make money it's not bad to bet on the
dogs jose aldo's the dog I see Joe's a
winning easy really yeah
I love I love Jersey although I just I
just now that was not like if the weight
cut slop rompford jozin he looks fine
against tomorrow it's a tough fight for
Peter yelling shoot for Peter he's a
monster anything great be in Russian but
it's not a shoe it just seems that so
much goddamn power boom just catches you
with those angles it's kind of
unforgiving so I don't know doesn't have
a ton of finishes you finish your eyes
bottom is like a big knockout artist
like you know they all would be the
knockout - how many finishes this yacht
have I just think he's so young and he's
so he's he looks so [ __ ] sound
fundamentally sound he does everything
right so out of his UFC fights yes Regis
engines three finishes yeah yeah he's my
favorite for god sakes which is
impossible to do yeah your eyes also 40
I mean you know yeah and and Josie has a
lot of miles on because I'd love to see
him win but I think if he does win it's
a it's a it's a big deal
it'd be it'd be a [ __ ] huge exciting
ring for you it yes and no I mean yeah
most people thought meet Marlon that's
why I gave him this fight you look at
the odds he's not that big of an
underdog either that's a close fight
that's a close fight I'm excited yeah
now the Beast but it's a lot for me chew
on it yeah so you think so Wow I thought
you definitely have young no I always go
for the underdogs bench
swish we played make money I like the
dogs in this card look man now we got we
got alexander prokhanov ski and max
great and I don't their [ __ ] book and
ask you with those goddamn leg kicks I
don't know what max is gonna do I here's
what I think if I miss camp I go like
this I say to max ago you have to knock
him out in the first [ __ ] around
max landed more headshots and body shots
he only lost with the lake leg kids so
if he addresses those leg kicks keeps
putting in some work and maybe not be so
stagnant maybe not take such a wide
stance
but then again you're assuming book nos
he's gonna come with the same game plan
which is like what you wouldn't do if he
came with the exact same game plan is
gonna lose like it you think max will
throw more leg kicks himself no I think
every time you throw him a good peg
right so he's gonna step in and jab imma
punch him yeah Volken asti he get his
thing that element of surprise is gone
so you can't do the same game plan
otherwise you're definitely gonna lose
can t max doesn't answer it was like
kids I bet you've woken up he starts
using his wrestling really you tried
taking down five times in their first
fight one suggest ball five but who
knows if he was purposely trying to do
it or if he was trying to mix it up I
think he comes again again I think that
I think that he's so [ __ ] awesome
Max's you know you can make learning the
best 45o of all time but then again he's
got a lot of mileage and I tend to go
with the younger I don't know if he even
focus he's younger but I think he has
less mileage no just like yeah I I find
myself going with a ski I get a dot I
mean Vegas is with you two men yes yeah
go to the main event son well a couple
things number one you got horses must be
though
I'm going with Moscow oh you can take it
on kids a big dog yeah but I but here's
the thing they say those months a better
wrestler that's fine but remember you
know Jorge months but I'll speak sis by
noon yeah and he's good French the guy I
don't know if you ever heard him called
Yoel Romero who's also a wrestler and
he's been he's been bringing in the best
wrestlers in the world apparently in
American Top Team he was Gus appraised
main sparring partner for the entire
time he's not been out of camp the only
question is that one that he was 194 I
think on Friday when he actually signed
the dotted line according to him that's
huge so he's got a lose or 192 he's got
to lose a little weight and travel and
there's sleep issues that that makes me
wondering about cardio what's gonna
happen that's a big factor but Maas
Pinellas is so [ __ ] good I think he's
a way better striker all due respect and
I don't think that he's gonna be
bothered by the restaurant so I gotta go
with Mozgov using [ __ ] get the done
via TKO or something I do I do
I mean look man it's it's it's a tall
order I lose mine is a monster and I'm
awesome but I just prefer shits and
giggles and fun no I don't know how to
fight
I feel like goostman doesn't get the
respect he deserves ever ever Woodley
look what he did to Colby commenting
like you monster man we also his cardio
is ridiculous he's so fun big and strong
he's just there's a reason he's a
champion I know he got that he got that
[ __ ] belt and did it decisively with
all of them and by the way his striking
is is punishing but I do think if he
tries to stand and banging with monster
god he's going to lose that exchange and
the advantage that Guzman may have his
cardio I don't know what his weights
been like you know you know yeah count
on that yeah we're weird I'm surprised
at the oddsmakers man Guzman zones
two-to-one favorite
yeah I don't know how you do that I
think they're thinking about wrestling I
think they're thinking about his size I
think they're thinking about his cardio
I think they're looking at Mazda gosh
wait cut that's got to do that's a big
way cut you know the travel you know but
and also what's my like you said this no
joke
but look it's Maserati it's just Mazda
dog I don't know how you put your you're
not putting your gloves on his face not
as much as he's putting them on yours
he's just I don't know man my great
fight way better fight than Gilbert
burns yeah this is just a fight we
wanted you know
if this fight doesn't [ __ ] kick the
cogut out of my chest man how's your
hundred kaupapa top it woke me up last
night it's a very strange thing cuz it
just lingers and it does to you what it
wants you're gonna you're gonna [ __ ]
your on coke that's train and kovat is
doing what the [ __ ] you just kind of
you're at the altar of Cobra you do what
the [ __ ] he says and that's the way it
is so you're just so weird out affected
both II know I know I'm a little younger
but I started that hydrochloric Queen
right away right that right away I
started IDs right away I get a lot of
Sun always yeah I've been trying to do
that too but I didn't do the
hydrochloric wine because I was I should
have done it when you did it earlier but
I wasn't told to do it so I asked a
couple of doctors they said don't done
right now I was like but it seems like
whatever you were doing with IP trips
and really help yeah well you never
really had a cost issue never had a
cough yeah see I got a call from me
nearly no no so again there's no way
every time I talk to any doctor they
kind of shake their head and go you know
they don't know
now just is weird for different people
yeah well yes I'm printer bench chin cat
we do one sec the best underwear on the
planet LGBT I know you're lounging
three-piece set is then comfy those mode
all me undies
well me um these are the best underwear
on planet here's why I've had tons of
our I've had on or sent to me every
every name brand you can think of and
the one that never seems to wear out the
one has the best resilience army undies
I just I died there might go to
underwear I agree you can get a
subscription plan so you get new undies
delivered every month whether you're a
freaking extra small or brine or you're
like myself gaming match your undies
with your girl or your dude and well no
the thing is that what I like is that
they seem to have literally grown to his
situation yeah and so and as you know I
have a situation where baggy and I
thought I had plenty of room it's like
wearing an old pair of like jeans that
the good teams that kind of like mold to
your body it's like an old pictures I
think they're made of clay but the
softest mode ah maybe I know right now
you're not feeling good buddy but when
you start to feel better I want you to
quit guessing about how many calories
you're burning how much sleep you're
getting what kind of workout you're
getting I want I'm gonna hook you up
with a little strap it goes around your
wrist dude I'll talk about woop the best
accessory to your workouts you're ever
gonna get buddy I'm talking I want it
now I want it now so I can see if it can
measure my incremental recovery
they can definitely do that take the
guesswork out and connects to your phone
via bluetooth all you have to do is
download the app you go to whoop calm
yeah that's what calm and to the promo
code fighter you get 15% off this
description and with the subscription
they monitor all your stuff man you're
gonna do a workout how many calories are
you actually burning
yeah while you sleep in Mars your sleep
I'm gonna recap how many hours you
actually get a good sleep uninterrupted
sleep we monitor all that did you want
your recovery you plan to push it hard
the next day know exactly the best time
to push it dome on your heart rate 100
times per second the loop strap man it's
easy as well I know there are two people
you and somebody else who does a lot of
exercise who had other sort of watches
that measure this stuff and apparently
the technology of whoo is not like this
app would tell me oh you burned 2300
calories seems off I got and I was
nowhere near that for the club so go to
woot.com promo code is fine are 50% off
this description enjoy take the
guesswork out with the best workout
accessory on the planet I'll talk about
tell you well buddy I need my vitamin D
that's where honor comes out there
vitamin D has actually been shown to
help ease the symptoms and apparently
the recovery in some studies of Kovan
well just so you think I'm doing a lot
of my a lot of my fish oil I'm doing a
lot of and you're sick and you're back
I'm not I take it all the time
my immune systems kind of bawling right
now and I feel good on it Broco fighter
you get 10% off the entire dam site
workout equipment workout devices need
on-demand training because you can't go
to the gym right now cool on six
on-demand workout kettlebell steel aces
protein powder krill oil we also like
exercise equipment my buddy called me
and said hey I need exercise equipment
I'm looking at who's looking at Bowflex
like go to [ __ ] on
calm and take a look at the stuff they
have because they have workouts that are
a half hour they correlate with whatever
it is the equipment do you buy and you
can get a we've done the workouts I
don't have any ties yeah good as it gets
guess poking powder they got how many
times got tell you on attempt welcome
[Music]
but back I believe it was 2011 Guy Fieri
flavortown got his Lamborghini stolen
while it was being serviced at San
Francisco the guy who stole was at the
time 16 years old just a random kid came
to the dealership stole his car police
officers couldn't find him for a whole
year even though there have been reports
that people have seen the car in San
Francisco for an entire year kind of
driving around they finally arrested him
he actually ended up getting life in
prison because he also tried to kill a
couple people so on time Phil a couple
people yeah Wow oh yeah the killing get
you like yeah I thought they got life in
prison pristine flavortown Lamborghini
but no he was arrested and life in
prison because of attempted murder well
you know they they in in the quality of
life crimes in New York City there was
this theory that people that do little
crime also do big crime if you do little
shitty things that you can get away with
if you if you're a shitty person and and
you you take what doesn't belong to you
and you lie and you steal especially
stealing and you if you take somebody's
possessions you know or whatever it
might be
chances are you are a very deeply
unethical person to begin with
mmm-hmm may you and you can draw a
parallel my experience has always been
if you really look at a person's life
and how they live their life how many
people do they help Wow how are they
behaving in chat
what do people say about them across the
board and and you know usually those
people haven't tracked we're gonna be in
[ __ ]
so it's not surprising that it's here
yeah I know sixteen year olds do crazy
things so I'm not saying he's still kart
64 said it would be 16 at the time but
now he's probably older and and you know
but sometimes people are just shitty and
they've done some research on even
children that are sort of psychotic
there there are there are like these
sort of not details but almost like
these Hospital / you know holding areas
for kids that are so impossible that
they had and put away from people and
then your attacks in an article about it
and they are they exhibit even at like
11 and 12 even younger they exhibit
classic sociopathic tendencies like try
and I'm sure they all have shitty
parents I'm sure no not that's the crazy
thing is a lot of them don't a lot of
them have very normal parents with
really normal siblings but the problem
is that one of them will try to kill one
of their siblings because it gets them
an advantage of something so there are
bad eggs born and it's a really
complicated rough thing to talk about
because you know the question becomes
are you born a bad egg sometimes but the
evidence scientifically apparently is
maybe no the evidence shows its most
your upbringing
that's the mutual it's both but we
definitely know let me restate before
but the majority would be you're up yes
yes yes 100%
100 there are there are people that just
are not born with that capacity to love
and care for people or even think about
other people well that flavor John kids
doing wasting life so Jesus yeah yeah
you stole a car 16 oh by the way trying
to kill a couple people not one person
with a couple keys all right where there
was a
who called the police on a birdwatcher
and she ended up having like her dog
taken away because he asked her to have
her dog on a leash do you guys remember
this yeah she's really gotten beat up
over this yeah so what's happening is
Manhattan is trying to proceed and such
charges against this woman for her hate
crime and the man equation Christian
Cooper is actually not cooperating with
the police because he says that he
thinks the public lynching that's
happening or on her end is punishment so
he doesn't want to actually help with
the office pressing charges this is a
good man this is a reasonable man this
is a real man and this is this is a who
most of America is black white whatever
I appreciate a guy like that whose guy
look the girl is [ __ ] crazy probably
having a moment she's not like that all
the time maybe she is but doesn't matter
such a [ __ ] weirdo or she's not now
or she was in that moment you know and
he's like I'm a what this is a we're
like he's not gonna be part of a
political lynching as what he said I
mean every lock their job she's like
what the house what else you want to do
with somebody like this and you end and
she's been blasted everywhere which
which you know which means you're you're
done because you had who knows maybe
she's hysterical maybe she has terrible
fear and anxiety maybe she's not right
mentally we don't know right nobody
knows who loves to just destroy you know
there was it there was a really
interesting thing about how all these
intellectuals from governments with
Marsalis no Chomsky you know writers and
artists intellectuals sign this whole
thing about how they're against cancel
culture how basically they are for free
speech the free flow exchange of ideas
we should all be able to express
ourselves even if they're not popular
let's have it that they it's just
America and all of those people suddenly
were like like this this box writer
who's a Tran
woman she she wanted her colleagues
signed it and she was an icon on public
blast on public glass shoes I don't want
to be fired or even recommend I just
don't feel safe with him there Simon say
anything to JK Rowling's sign because
Jackie around I said that woman is a
woman and a man and so I don't feel safe
oh yeah baby but but but it was
retweeted thirteen thousand times so you
don't want them to be you don't have me
what you don't have to cancel so so the
people that signed this thing that was
just for free speech are now being
attacked and some of the people that
sided like I had no idea that JK
Rowling's sided I'm so sorry you [ __ ]
you little [ __ ] sign the [ __ ]
thing it's just about free speech the
free flow exchange of ideas so I'm gonna
talk more on this eventually right now
it's a funny time o61
she's only 61 she refuses to get old
poor Madonna she's not gonna go gently
into the night issue she's doing some
weird stuff on mine man
supposed to hurry have you seen Britney
Spears it's crazy
have you seen me no oh boy it's very
interesting it was brought to my
attention I don't wanna I don't like
gossiping and I don't know what's what's
going on so I don't want to I want to be
gentle with her and I don't want to it's
just interesting is I was showing me the
my girl showed me all the you know all
the videos on Instagram and I was like
Instagram yeah yeah
yeah like just just watch this one watch
the yellow watch this
unless she broke her ankle that's all
she does okay and then you might want to
watch some so I have to make sure we
don't play the music cuz I can okay
there's anything without music they all
have music I'm sure yeah they do
like this one too it's really
interesting I'm she's just bored as [ __ ]
I don't know what's going on power of
attorney
she's bipolar he's like forcing her in
certain performances or forbidding her
to do certain things yeah it's it's
interesting I don't know it's it's it's
yeah well I hope she's okay yeah it just
makes me see it it makes me it's a bomb
she was she a while ago - I
she lost who she was a while ago she's
sort of just existing right now yeah
like a show which is that well I hope
she finds I don't know I don't know all
right yeah I'm sure it is I'm sure you
guys think this was gonna come so the US
government Mike Pompeo is saying that
they might actually ban tik-tok you know
it was populist probably the most
popular app right now right right
tik-tok and why would they they ban it
give the Chinese government can get
access to everyone's information yep you
know Clark's dinner just like most of
our apps - right so they're worried that
the data will be grabbed by the Chinese
government
Connie's party yeah so they're actually
considering banning that actual app
which is popular right now
well we have to just invent our own app
that has an encrypted technology I don't
think you want the Chinese government
getting into everybody's American phone
yes tik toks big with the younger
audience right it's not a lot of adults
are on there exactly the younger but
then now we're getting on it celebrities
stars older stars you're on it it's also
like you don't know what they can if
they can use spy technology to use the
phone to watch other things going on
their show and you have a child and
that's tick-tock so they're actually
worried that the Chinese go - no we'll
just seize that information and take it
away from those people they're you know
the users but yeah I think all our apps
are pretty much susceptible to that -
trouble for that and they passed a long
Californian now they can't really do
that and also there there's an American
pop you know he wouldn't want to make
sure you want to mem you would want to
make sure there's nothing like that
happens but of course the government's
gonna be really really something else
hey Brendan you look like you're on an
alter Murr you sacrifice but you worship
is that really worship Savior I mean I
can if you want well you have candles
there dude they're got candles what the
[ __ ] is going on I don't know are those
made from blood art that art is the big
that's a big independent controller or
is it or is it just a maze to get closer
to Beelzebul are you doing worship
they'll support all right this is a 73
year old woman I'll play some stuff
fishy
I get off for this [ __ ] : I'm gonna be
all over this [ __ ] anyways all day far
let's feeling some [ __ ] good before
this ah so sucks okay this is amazing
there's nothing more annoying than
somebody who's sick talking about being
sick
I'm great like whatever
alright she's walking with giant plates
and then you'll see are you some more
stuff here that [ __ ] egg this video
sucks cuz I'll play Knightly so I'll
show you the pictures here yeah I'm
getting mad just pointing there with
their 41 year old trainer
she's on a handstand
at 70s good for her
they're inspiring okay that's Brian
accounting eventually later
so who st. bolt had a daughter recently
that really super cute named Olympia
right no Olympia lightning cutie pie so
cute alright go to this real quick the
Fox News had a thing about Maxwell and
they use a picture of Epstein and
Melania and and Duane but then they
cropped out trouble and they're
apologizing on accident cuz you know Fox
News in chopper very pretty cool they're
usually pro-trump yeah so this is the
actual but yeah I would say that all
three of those things are there are
three different purposely crop them off
but this is the actual thing right there
I mean both sides do it CNN does their
share of Photoshop [ __ ] they all
just have an agenda
alright why didn't you lane Maxwell or
whatever name is go to France where they
don't have
where she would have been kind of safe
with her billions yeah and I thought she
was out the per second he came back I
don't know well the question is maybe
she knows something that we don't know
maybe she's got an ace in the hole maybe
she already worked out a deal yeah we'll
see yeah cuz she's too smart she knows
they were gonna track her down here in
the state yeah she bought a house like
driving distance from the DA yeah so
they had to literally come and pick her
up to the cars so it's like she I think
she worked out a deal I think that names
are gonna be named oh yeah and it's
interesting I want to see what happens
because but but the question is
hopefully she's got Kovac dude and she's
60 something oh so now she'll be in the
hospital at the end of the day if she
was working and Epstein were working for
a foreign intelligence agency let's say
like the Israelis the Israelis can do
what the [ __ ] the Mossad can get to you
I would imagine yeah so I know I'm not a
big conspiracy guy I don't know if
Jeffrey Epstein on himself
I don't know I'm not gonna get into it I
don't know the details I mean shot I
mean uh Rogan was like look into it he
actually thinks it Jeff didn't kill
himself
so what the [ __ ] do I know but I will
say this is just jillaine it just Lane
Maxwell makes it through this or she
mysteriously dies of komen makes do I
wonder what name she has what's that I
said hopefully she makes it through it I
want to know what [ __ ] information
she has yeah that's the big question
yeah you're talking about [ __ ] big
names oh man you're talking about like
and if you're talking about underage
girls if you're talking about like I
don't I didn't read a lot about where
they're like 14 year olds 15 year olds
yeah well there's probably video I mean
I don't know that's the yeah that's
conspiracy that they had video running
to make sure
maybe one of the initiatives a bunch of
gals who are like him a twenty-something
it's different yeah you know there's got
to be very powerful men [ __ ] in
their pastor Bill Clinton and then also
because he's with Hillary Clinton's
already got a litany of this behavior
history all right this guy when you go
on your outside you see like people
pushing a little cart with ice cream in
it yeah you know talking about the I
grew up selling them he's almost 70
years old and then he injured himself
not too long ago so that's why he used
to work as a carpenter and he had to
start doing as the ice cream ice cream
job and then someone found him and they
bought all of his I think the couple
Olympics right they put all of it and
did a GoFundMe account
so he bought all of all of the stuff
amigos
we want you to have just enjoy your
father's age go home and very beautiful
they set up a GoFundMe account for
Bryan's car move on to you know Floyd
Mayweather's on cameo guess who charges
more than he so he's like the
second-highest charging for cameo but
there's one person that charges more
than any guesses what no and you know
Chris was parroting like Chris is
charging like 10 yeah it's not guesses
no okay
Caitlin dinner 25 now
whoa how much 2,500 bucks yeah dude I
charge a hundred bucks and always will
and you donate to charity yeah I do well
lately I've been spending it but yes no
I do I do I actually haven't spent it
but yes I've spent on charity a lot of
money hmm I know you guys both thing so
that's where your night I know but
because I get criticized for it because
cameo now over my various charities
choice yeah okay well that's pretty much
it
dang that think gang well we got we had
a quick one today hopefully we're in the
studio next week we're gonna figure you
out B if you're still not helped about
next week yeah I do one more zoom I'm
gonna slip I'm sorry I just got to be
responsible and make sure I'm not
contained just obviously I'm not gonna
come into the studio yeah so we need to
be careful of that we're this is a this
is a really weird time in American
history we don't know what's gonna
happen with this thing we don't know
what's happening with all our businesses
Hollywood's in real trouble and a lot of
the comedy clubs are remaining closed I
just talking to some people who own a
lot of clubs this morning and they don't
know what T see a comedy club can only
make money they can't make money when
they're operating at 60%
they can't even break even yeah so
that's a huge problem so you're dealing
with all these these initiatives and
you've got that state boards help don't
really know either everybody's trying to
figure this [ __ ] out everything I
surprised me dies I took two tests I'm
down there so people are asking
to make sure yes of course I took two
different tests and awaiting the results
back yeah well I'm glad you're feeling
okay yes very important I'll take
another test today so good luck man
thank you guys all right guys well that
take kids
oh my my taken July off all July dates
have been rescheduled that it Brian hey
buddy I miss the fun kid Wow